I'm saying if they're with a man none of
them would prefer to be with a man that
they respect and admire I didn't say a
man that they don't respect and don't
admire I said a man that they respect
and admire none of them would pick that
over being alone I don't know that is
also perspective
sorry guys I think who is single choose
to be single we live in a world with the
day chap everyone
hold on okay you see these 60 year old
women who are just living their best
life yeah are they still dating yes why
are they still dating because they are
the people the personal knowledge lost
their their husbands and start to do
dates Now find the boyfriend and enjoy
life again
if they were so happy being single why
are they doing that
I think like is about to do whatever you
feel to do if you want to be single
you'll be single day